[Music]
in the aftermath of 9/11 I quit my
career as a doctor so I could serve in
the Air Force as a pilot and at the end
of my 13-year career I had the
opportunity to work as a dual qualified
pilot and physician I was an operational
test pilot in a nuclear bomber as well
as a flight surgeon and there was 11 of
us in the entire Air Force at the time
and over my service I had the privilege
and honor to work for so many incredibly
inspiring talented and motivating
leaders but over that time I also saw
how often our senior leaders fell short
of what we needed them to be and that's
why I'm on this stage today I want to
improve Air Force leadership and make it
the service that this nation needs it to
be specifically by focusing on how we
improve our leaders to help you
understand the leadership gap that I'm
talking about I want to share with you a
tale of two leaders one of my first
commanders in one of my earliest
squadrons that I joined two months prior
to me getting there he had taken over
that squadron after the previous
commander had been fired there was a
nuclear missile incident that had
reached national attention and when I
joined this squadron was under intense
scrutiny by the entire Air Force and
even higher up to make sure that that
mistake never happened again and this
meant working through grueling
inspections and exercises basically
simulating World War 3 and if any of us
made a mistake where we decoded a
nuclear message incorrectly or had a
procedural misstep the entire base fails
careers are ended and it was during this
intense period of scrutiny that my wife
and I received some difficult news we
learned that naomi was going to need a
kidney transplant we didn't know when
but it was going to happen and that's
when my commander whose callsign was
rude wasn't rude at all just his
callsign but I remember he came up to me
one day and he said Dave listen I heard
what's going on with your wife I've
talked to my boss
and we think it's best that you just
take some time off I know we're severely
undermanned for this next inspection but
I think you need to focus on your family
the fact that he cared so much about my
family more than his career just maybe
you want to work ten times harder for
this man and that's simply because he
understood a very simple fact there's a
difference between what the Air Force
pays us to do and what it asks us to do
and leadership is what makes up that
difference leaders like rude now over
the next two years we completed all our
inspections with flying colors we
completed a successful deployment we
also had a jet crash and we lost several
of our own but through all of this I was
part of a team that was so committed to
each other their job and their boss
and I wouldn't trade that for anything
now contrast that experience with
another commander that I had went by the
call sign of Panzer and when he joined
our squadron his reputation already
preceded him and I remember early on he
walked up to one of the young pilots in
our squadron and he goes hey captain I
understand you're gonna weapon school
right after this six-month deployment so
you might be away from your family for
about an entire year I was just thinking
what if we just keep you back and you
just go to weapons school for six months
instead of going on this deployment
captain looks at a month he goes well
gee sir that's not a bad idea at all I
mean I just spent six months deployed
last year my wife just delivered our
first child three weeks ago maybe it
wouldn't be such a bad idea idea if I
just focused on preparing for weapons
school Panzer looks at him again that's
not what I wanted to hear when I asked
you if you want to deploy the only thing
I want to hear from you is so you
I'll do whatever you want me to do for
you sir three days later this pilot and
the rest of us are assembled in our
squadron getting ready to deploy and he
gets up in front of the entire squadron
understand we've all said goodbye to our
families children are still crying in
the parking lot but he gets up to
address all of us and he goes today
we're gonna deploy we're gonna do what
we've been trained to do now we're all
thinking we're gonna get one of those
rousing patriotic speeches you hear
about in the movies maybe this guy isn't
so bad after all
and you know what's so great about
deploying I get to get the hell away
from my wife and kids I don't have to go
to any of my daughter's damn baseball
games anymore look I mean we're just as
shocked as you are
I mean this is the guy that's gonna lead
us into combat
turns out this incident was really a
sign of things to come because the next
two years we dealt with a great deal of
his malfeasance misconduct and general
misbehavior and no amount of
investigations and evidence that piled
up against what he had done was gonna
make a difference basically up the chain
they swept it under the rug and made it
go away those two years really rather
uneventful but we as a squadron were
left completely broken demoralized doing
the bare minimum to get through each day
and counting the days that we were going
to be able to get out of this unit I
wish there was a better ending to this
story but the fact of the matter is rude
my earlier commander his career
plateaued he's no longer in the Air
Force Panzer is in line to be a general
in the US Air Force today why does this
matter to anyone here
well the US Air Force is in a serious
crisis right now that affects our
national security
pilots are getting out of the Air Force
as soon as their commitments up there
are cockpits going unfilled right now
and it poses a serious threat to our
security we're not able to do our
mission anymore most people aren't aware
of this fact and what I've watched is
the Air Force talk about how we need to
pay the pilots more change the
deployment schedule and that's missing
the heart of the matter here
pilots aren't quitting their jobs
they're quitting their bosses bosses who
don't care about their people as much as
they care about their own promotion
bosses who won't speak truth to power
boss is like Panzer I've had the great
opportunity to spend the last year at
business school at Stanford and I've
looked over how we can fix this problem
I've looked at the private sector looked
at the HR practices and the talent
management strategies strategies that I
think will make a difference and three
of the top things that I think the Air
Force can do to really make it into what
this nation needs it to be our hiring a
professional search firm 360 valuations
and neuropsychiatric evaluations and let
me explain what I'm talking about
hire a professional search firm that can
come in and identify exactly what kind
of leader you need what kind of skills
characteristics and experiences these
leaders should have and once you've
built your target you can just work
backwards from there and develop a set
of promotion criteria that can identify
develop and select those specific
leaders right now in my opinion we have
an arbitrary gauntlet of promotion
criteria designed to see who wants to be
promoted the most instead of having
promotion criteria developed to see what
kind of leaders we need the most number
two
360 evaluations we
all done this in business school and a
lot of companies this is standard
operating procedure I would argue that
the people at the bottom of the chain
are often in the best position to
identify the best leaders look I think
we can all agree anyone can look good
for the priest on Sunday morning it's
how you act on Saturday night that tells
me really what kind of person you are
and third neuropsychiatric testing now
this one really caught me off guard I
didn't realize that so many companies
were already doing this to make sure
that they identified and promoted the
best leader turns out army special
forces and Navy SEALs already employ
neuropsychiatric testing to pick through
all of their recruits you can be the
biggest fastest strongest recruit in
Navy SEAL training but if your test
comes back showing narcissistic or
sociopathic tendencies you're done
you're out
Special Forces don't tolerate people
they can't trust neither should the Air
Force conveniently the Air Force has all
this data for every one of its pilots I
and everyone else spend five hours
taking this IQ test and personality test
before we go to pilot training
it's just that they only revisit those
results in the event that one of us has
a head injury and we need to be cleared
before we can fly again so professional
search firms 360 valuations and
neuropsychiatric testing that's what I
think would make a real difference and
this is pretty standard in the private
sector so why aren't we moving the
needle on this in the military if things
are getting so bad well I've talked to
military leaders political scientists
and famous authors on this topic and
they all agree this is a growing problem
and something needs to be done about
this but the only thing that's going to
fix it is an attack on the scale of
Pearl Harbor what why do we need to
sacrifice blood and treasure to get an
organization to embrace embrace true
leader
ship I'm not asking for a billion
dollars
and I'm not asking to send a Tesla
Roadster to Mars
it's simple standard private sector HR
practices but I will admit it is
difficult the three things that any
organization is going to need to embrace
to implement these decisions in these
actions our first have the strength to
look in the mirror and embrace the
uncomfortable truth staring back at you
to discipline have the discipline to
take action before you've run out of all
other options and finally moral clarity
have the moral clarity to put purpose
above promotion thank you
[Applause]
[Music]